hi everyone I'm so happy to be here
today I'm going to talk about our Python
project for how to work a few words
about me my name is the family hi I'm a
software engineer I graduated about 10
years ago from the Hebrew University I
love technology and I love this event
I'm really excited to be here so what is
Hawksworth hak-soo is one of the biggest
hackathons in europe it's a really
exciting event where hundreds of
designers that the scientists and
engineers gather for about 40 hours of
coding that's a brilliant experience and
I really recommend it definitely feel
free to come and ask me questions about
it today I'm going to talk about the
challenge that we took and usually
hackathons offer challenges like some
sort of a coding problem or some data
set with an open question
hugs are offered about 16 challenges and
we decided to take the Millennials on
the move basically we wanted to use data
to increase safety on the roads so what
was the data that was given to us first
of all it's important to see that the
data was gathered using a dedicated
hardware it was installed in the car so
you can see here in the pictures that
some of the data is fixed like the
vehicle year or the age of the driver
and some of it is what was sampled every
few seconds like the gear spatial data
the speed the engine rpm so that sounds
kind of trivial but how can you take
that and make something useful out of
them so the first thing we wanted to do
with it is to classify dangerous areas
the reason is that we thought that it
could be a comprehensive solution from
the one hand we can give the authorities
the list of these areas and maybe they
can improve infrastructures and on the
other hand maybe we can give some
information to the drivers while they're
in these dangerous zones and what we did
for that another thing that is really
important for asset
to do we didn't want it to be another
app we didn't wanted it to be some
another cause for distraction so you can
see the demo that we showed in the
hackathon it's very simple but think
about it we wanted it to be installed in
the car and just give some information
to the driver while he's driving so you
can see that the car is entering a
junction that's it not a lot of
information not to overload the driver
and you can see that when it exits the
the junction it becomes green again it's
not all the early just specific the road
that he's in okay so the first thing we
did we just took the information and put
it on the map it's really nice to see
that it's it's kind of intuitive it
doesn't give us a lot of information
even though it's a nice thing to see so
we decided we need to do some
manipulation about the data with the
data so we can extract more valuable
information from it and we decided to
focus on the speed so we we used the
information that we have as drivers and
we said okay if we take examined two
sequential points in time and we see
that the speed decreases in like 75%
probably something happens here because
the driver hit the bricks so the each
point that with each sequential point in
time that we saw the this difference we
took the location and we decided this
location is an alarm okay so we focused
on speed but you can thinking we could
do the same maybe with different
criteria so now when we have this
locations from the alarm set you can see
here from one driver all the alarm sets
you can see that some of them are
injunctions which it does make sense but
some of them are not like you can know
where these alarms will be at so the
next step is to take all these alarms
from all the drivers in all the
different trips you can see that they
have different colors these different
alarms and to cluster them into areas so
in this way automatically you can you
can cluster the areas and you can also
add some threshold say
we have different clusters but then only
if a cluster is big enough according to
some some treasure that you have this is
a dangerous area
and in this process you can actually
automatically identify dangerous areas
okay so we did this process but we also
wanted to validate our data validate our
results so we use the UK safety data set
of car accidents we actually did this
manually but for sure you can automate
this process we just wanted to see that
the results we receive are actually
valid so now now when you have this
information you have some assumption
here okay you have an assumption that um
most of the drivers in most of the
drives most of the right trips
did you drive responsibly and carefully
so if you have one area with a lot of
alarms probably something happened there
so you can now go back to the
authorities and see maybe the signs are
not visible maybe there's a problem with
the road maybe there's something we can
do and to increase safety and now you
can also in real time give information
to the driver and because you know the
the system can know what is the the
current what is the GPS coordinates
where the car is and you can just say
okay in specific areas you can just
alert the driver so we would be drive
more responsibly or just look at the
world again and just know that you can
do this process you can use the data in
two different ways one of them you can
say okay I'm just going to look at the
drivers information and to have
dangerous zones that are personalized
for him maybe he has specific problems
in specific time type of junctions and
you can also do the same as I showed
with all the drivers and all the data
set and for like a general dangerous
variants okay so we did that can we do
more with the data we thought we can so
we
we took all that all the speed in all
the areas and we created a heat map and
and you can see it's just a simple
Python the histogram you can see it was
really nice for us to see how it really
laid the road nicely if you compare it
to the map we didn't use any map it's
just buckets and like you ever just
speed and in a way you can see that this
is an empirical way of saying how the
drivers behave in in this area and what
can you do with that okay you can see
here it's the same place where you saw a
lot of alarms before so it's it's a bit
of a different way to approach the data
but it shows above the same thing you
can see that there's an open road over
there and the speed is pretty high and
then just before the junction everyone
hit the brakes so what can you do with
that if before we use the location now
we can use the speed in the car and if
there's a difference between the current
car speed and this ever speed and if we
cross some threshold you can also allow
the driver and you can tweak that a
little bit you can change it according
to the weather or if there's some
temporary constructions on the road or
if you know if you want to tweak it
personalized to the driver maybe
according to his age or is experiencing
surfing you can do that too and again
you can go back with this information
with with this kid map think about it
when when traffic engineers put the all
the speed limits and in places they
didn't they didn't have this empirical
data it's like a rule of thumb to say
okay we need to put a sign here and
maybe now when you do have this map you
can adjust it better so I wrote a blog
post about it and I got really curious
because this specific Junction we just
use it in the hackathon you know we have
like two days and you're so tired and
just used one of them it wasn't even it
wasn't necessarily a junction that was
highly clustered and so I like took a
virtual ride on Google Maps and I
actually could see the road and I could
see how I could drive there and then
just when you enter just when you see
the junction
when it's visible you have this speed
limit son like you literally don't have
one before so you know just put one it
can help the driver to slowly and safely
get to the junction so I just wanted to
say that we eventually we ended up
winning this project tired they're very
happy and it was a great wait teamwork
for all the awesome engineers at it I
have a blog post about it if you're
interested more and also we have the
code and feel free to comment ask
questions
[Applause]